هكذا تبدو بيروت من الاعلى
عاصمه لبنان التي لقبت بمدينه البطون
امتلات اسطح امنيتها بالواح الطاقه
الشمسيه
جهود فرديه مبعثره اعتقد اللبنانيون انها
ستخرجهم من ازمه انقطاع التيار الكهربائي
ولكن مع غياب الرقابه ودخول الدخلاء
الى ورش تركيب الواح الطاقه ادى الى
احتراقها وتطايرها احيانا لبنان
طرف حوالي 900 مليون دولار لو صرفناهم
بطريقه منظمه كانت الحلول حتكون افضل افضل
منظمه منها مشوهه للبيئه خطر على السلامه
العامه و ثانيا كمان كنت بتكون مفيده اكثر
من ناحيه انتاج الكهرباء والكل يقدر
يستفيد
شركه ابي حيدر في صياغه قانون الطاقه
المتجدده الموزعه لتنظيم القطعه لكنه
وزاره الطاقه لم تاخذ به رغم مرور ثلاثه
اعوام هي نفس الوزاره التي بنت على مقربه
منها اول حقل شمسينا مزاجيه في لبنان وهو
مشروع الطاقه الشمسيه الوحيد الذي تعاهدت
به الدوله ليتبين ان كل هذه الالواح لا
تعمل بسبب ربطها بخط تغذيه خال من الطاقه
في ظل التقنين الحادث
مثال عن سوء الاداره التي حدثنا عنها غسان
بيضون مديره عامل استثمار السابق في وزاره
الطاقه
لحتى تاخذ الالتزام بالاستثمار همم
[موسيقى]
وزير مش عام مدير
المصالحه ومصالح المستثمرين اللي بيدعموه
بناء الحقول في مناطق نائيه واستجرار
الطاقه للمدن والكره لكن اعتماد المواطنين
على انفسهم لتامين الواح الطاقه ادى الى
الصرف الكثير من الاموال مقابل القليل من
الاستفاده كان بامكان الطاقه البديله ان
تتحول الى جزء من حل مستدام لمشكله
الكهرباء في لبنان لكن الفساد والفضه كان
كافيلين كالعاده بتحويل النعمه الى نقمه
اغنيه يتيم العربيه بيروت